here's the latest hello
Iraq I have a question sure don't know
what is it you know that State of the
Union thing the President does every
year and anyone ever done it over
Twitter using only emojis no though it's
an important okay great I just wanted to
make sure I'd be the first bomb again
you're gonna regret it if you don't have
a back-up plan we have a back-up plan
ruins one of them we're just trying to
look all surprised like we didn't know
what backup plan
we didn't know we need to come up with
one that's not a back-up plan
that's way hello one week bear yeah I
know one week until you're sworn in
No one week is how long I've had this
DVD of dr. T and the women once dr. T
and the women
it's a bolita Richard Gere guess who he
plays you give up knowledge just don't
care he's playing CT I guess who Helen
uh place one of the women's bingo
anyway I got in some bread boxes a week
ago and I watched it a you want dr. T
and the women eight times this week
don't you have other stuff to worry
about you're right you're right I gotta
watch the DVDs flash Oh God salad guys
for the waist up in that movie so from
the way down come on
I gotta tell you about the presidents
could be a lot of work more than you
bargained for huh oh man this is gonna
be the toughest for buds of my life for
years the presidential term is four
years you're kidding
[Applause]
you